[Music]
all right no one sanctions china and
gets away with it apparently president
xi retaliating against anyone who calls
out the ccp's abuse of uighur muslims in
the shangjing region now four american
members of the u.s commission get this
on the international religious freedom
have been sanctioned china's goal
creating a chilling effect for future
critics around the world will it work
one of the only people brave enough in
and out of sports to stand up to china
and said to their silencing uh and the
silencing of other nbls uh nba stars uh
iz and his cantor freedom who recently
became an american citizen uh of the
boston celtics ennis how do you feel
about them sanctioning american
officials for calling them out for
genocide
unbelievable you know i feel like these
are a lame attempt to retaliate against
the us for leading the world and
responding to the mass genocide against
weakers in china and you know the us was
the first country to sanction key
officials and entities responsible for
the atrocities is leading the global by
a boycott of the winter olympics and you
know just last week
uh you know we passed the uyghur force
labor prevention act they're ensuring
that goods made in xinjiang with forced
labor do not enter our markets and i
want to hear from i want to give a huge
shout out to my friend uh sandra rubio
and also representative jim mccombe
leading the way i think it's really
important to hold these dictatorships
accountable and they are leading the way
you are wearing the shoes calling out
china you are calling out nike you are
calling out the nba for even wanting to
do deals with china and they're losing
millions of dollars annis have you felt
the backlash have you felt the pressure
to take off those shoes and stop
speaking out
of course i mean once i started this
whole campaign obviously
not many people uh liked it especially
from ir league you know they would just
keep pressuring me to take their shoes
off but i was like you know this is my
freedom of speech and you're not going
to tell me what to do and go to tell
your boss about that and uh obviously
once they saw that i'm standing uh
strong against uh my first amendment
they get a give up but i think it is
important to like i said like i said
again hold these associations companies
and organizations accountable because
when they call themselves a social
justice organizations or companies they
just they only obviously donate in
america but when it
touches countries like china where they
when they're making billions of dollars
right they remain
and someone had to uh call him out
former new york nicki's uh journeyman in
the nba had his brief moment jeremy lin
is now playing in china and you called
him out saying basically how could you
be playing for that horrible uh
government what is your problem with him
playing over there i mean first time
first time i tweet about that obviously
i know that he's from you know
california and but he's you know
taiwanese american and we already we
everyone knows what taiwan and taiwanese
people are going through right now and i
believe that you know it's it was just
to me it was just little you know
ashamed that he is making so much money
from here
you know from china from in beijing
where his country obviously are going
through and he's people going through it
could be invaded at any moment real
quick and as you believe the nba should
stop playing i mean we're the there's so
many players testing positive they can't
get enough on the court i think the nets
had 10 players out the other day why are
they why why don't you think they took a
pause like the nhl did
um so i
so i believe you know uh i mean
eight of our micro uh
plays in our team tested by a positive
and is actually affecting our season you
know but i mean to nba or for nba
obviously they are caring about making a
lot of money and obviously the the
christmas day is a huge day they have
fought for mba but i heard and so from
some of the officials that you know they
might think about postponing the season
after christmas but i was like come on
man you know it has to be you know
safety over money not the other way
around but you know i hope that they
make the right decisions and i know this
we need support in our life but i just
want people to be safe right i just
heard we're trying to get confirmation
that the nhl might not be going to the
olympics that would be interesting
by the way
i actually just heard recently and i
applaud by the great courage and i want
all the associations all the
organizations out there are just taking
us about what they're doing you know wta
and nhl leading the way i mean what are
we waiting for why are we talking about
the genocide happening and it's a shame
to you know this organizes olympic games
in uh china so come on he's one of
america's newest citizens and we're
proud to have him dennis cantor thanks
so much i hope your family gets to join
you here soon best of luck for the
celtics rest of the way i appreciate
that all right unless they play the
knicks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else